you might actually want to hold off for  just another nine months because the  leaks for the new iphone 14 models are  pointing to some of the biggest changes  we've seen in years so let's get right  into it we're basically getting four new  iphone 14 models two with a 6.1 inch  display and then two with a 6.7 inch  display both the pro models they  actually are going to come with 120  hertz pro motion technology will be  getting a 48 megapixel camera that 48  megapixel sensor is going to give you  incredibly sharp photos in very bright  conditions but unfortunately having that  many pixels is going to reduce low light  camera quality so apple is going to have  a solution which is pixel bidding so  you're essentially getting the best of  both worlds like super sharp 48  megapixel photos for bright conditions  as well as 8k video recording but then  when it's dark outside it's going to use  pixel binning to create larger pixels  with a 12 megapixel photo for better  quality